[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva visión de
los observadores de france 24 esta
semana haremos un balance de las
esperanzas defraudadas de la revolución
egipcia con uno de nuestros observadores
10 años después de la caída de hosni
mubarak luego iremos a manaos en brasil
donde unos ciudadanos se movilizan en
contra la segunda ola de kobe 19 que
está siendo muy letal
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace diez años después de túnez egipto
fue el segundo país árabe en sublevarse
contra el régimen en el poder de hosni
mubarak
nuestro observador en la activista ramy
raoof fue parte de los miles de egipcios
que estuvieron en la plaza tahrir en el
cairo en febrero de 2011 en esa emisión
habló sobre su movilización a pesar de
la represión 10 años después lo volvimos
a contactar se acuerda de un periodo de
euforia y esperanza que hoy parece muy
lejano como durante la revolución en
egipto en 2011 las autoridades cortaban
progresivamente las comunicaciones
entonces algunas personas podían tener
acceso a internet antes de que se
cortara por completo entonces se
constituyó un archivo visual muy
importante alrededor de la revolución
egipcia en esa época las organizaciones
de defensa de los derechos humanos le
ayudaban a los manifestantes en las
calles y yo naturalmente me interesaba
por lo que pasaba en la sociedad egipcia
y participe en la revolución el hecho de
conmemorar la revolución o de conmemorar
cualquier evento político importante
para mí también significa celebrar
la idea de la esperanza la esperanza por
un cambio y el sueño después de un
paréntesis con los hermanos musulmanes
el ejército volvió a tomar el control
del país en 2013 y frustró las
esperanzas de los manifestantes de la
primavera árabe desde hace algunos años
en cada aniversario de la revolución
egipcia las fuerzas de seguridad que
organizan controles aleatorios los
teléfonos de los transeúntes en las
calles son revisados para rastrear
cualquier contenido que pueda ser
crítico del régimen hoy en día el
movimiento de protesta es ampliamente
acallado hoy en día es difícil porque la
militarización actual que hay en el país
ha amenazado cualquier conmemoración de
este evento los últimos cinco años
afectaron al país y cualquier
conmemoración se volvió complicada desde
hace un tiempo las autoridades ejercen
un control sobre el espacio público y
ahí se trata de las calles las plazas
las comunicaciones las universidades la
educación todo eso a través de la
elaboración de varias leyes por ejemplo
la infraestructura de las
telecomunicaciones en egipto le
pertenece a leds
y el estado le alquila esos servicios a
las empresas de telecomunicaciones y el
estado puede controlar en cierta medida
los servicios que ofrecen las empresas
de telecomunicaciones también he visto
que entre más refuerza la vigilancia más
creativa se vuelven las personas
aprenden a utilizar diferentes
herramientas que les permiten
comunicarse actualmente las personas
siguen utilizando internet como un
espacio que les permite expresarse y
organizarse a pesar de todas las formas
de vigilancia que existen se estima que
desde 2014 60.000 personas han sido
detenidas por razones políticas la
última detención registrada fue la del
dibujante ashraf handy el 24 de enero
justamente había publicado un dibujo por
los 10 años de la sublevación
la ciudad brasileña de manaos ya había
sufrido mucho con la primera ola de kobe
19 la segunda ha sido todavía peor con
un mes de enero particularmente letal
desde el comienzo del año los llamados
de auxilio de los ciudadanos se han
multiplicado ante la falta de oxígeno en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos
estamos en una situación lamentable
simplemente no hay oxígeno en toda la
unidad de cuidados no hay oxígeno muchas
personas se están muriendo por favor si
tienen los medios si tienen oxígeno
necesitamos oxígeno aquí en el servicio
de urgencias de la policlínica repensado
muchas personas se están muriendo por el
amor de dios ante esta escasez varios
colectivos ciudadanos de manaos lanzaron
en enero la campaña ese o ese amazonas
para ayudarle al personal de salud con
donaciones de materiales y una buena
organización usado me lo es uno de los
organizadores
la idea de la campaña era ayudar con
agua y alimentos y de repente un perfil
en instagram publicó una de nuestras
fotos y la campaña se volvió viral
puesto a nuestra foto y ahí finalizó
entonces pudimos trabajar sobre la
principal demanda en el seno del estado
porque estábamos viendo morir a muchas
personas a causa de la falta de oxígeno
fue algo que nunca habíamos visto
con el dinero de las donaciones
empezamos a comprar varios cilindros de
oxígeno y a llevarlos después a otros
estados de brasil y atrás de huxford y
otros y estar montados en manaos es poco
accesible por carretera
entonces el material llega por avión o
por el río un tome un edificio logística
para acá entonces la logística es muy
complicada
nosotros hacemos esa negociación con las
empresas de aviación vamos a buscar las
donaciones al aeropuerto también somos
nosotros los que hacemos la distribución
en los hospitales
con voluntarios y con la ayuda de la
policía civil
publicamos muchas informaciones en
nuestro instagram hacemos vídeos en vivo
explicamos lo que hacemos para ser
transparentes con todas las personas que
quieran acompañar nuestra acción ya nos
acción
agradecemos a todos nuestros
observadores que nos informan sobre lo
que ocurre a su alrededor
si usted también quiere contarnos sobre
alguna situación que nos indigna o una
bonita historia todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla esperamos con
impaciencia sus fotos y videos para
cubrir juntos la actualidad
internacional a través de imágenes de
aficionados hasta pronto
[Música]